MALE SPEAKER: Shanghai
GDG is a very
interesting developer community.
FEMALE SPEAKER: I'm
glad somebody
has asked this question.
MALE SPEAKER: And this is
where the magic happens.
FEMALE SPEAKER: This
is primarily a
question-and-answer show.
So if any of you out there would
like to ask questions--
STEVE BAZYL: Hi, everyone.
This is Stephen Bazyl here for
another "Google Developers
Live." Today we--
or me, rather, since this
is a solo endeavor--
I'm going to be taking a look
at an OS 10 app for Google
Drive called Archy.
Basically what Archy is is a
full implementation of the
Drive web interface, but
done as a native
application for Macs.
And I thought this would be a
good comparison since a few
weeks ago, we did an app review
of an Android client
called ASTRO, which is a file
manager for Android devices,
which did a lot of the same
functionality in terms of
implementing access to Drive as
a file system from within
their application.
And it'd be a good comparison
to see how that translates
over to a full desktop
application.
So the Archy application-- is
going to to take a look at
their website really quick--
it is still beta.
It's very early access
right now.
But as an OS 10 user myself,
I have to say it's actually
really nicely done
application.
I take a little bit of issue
with their "bringing Google
Drive to the humans" claim.
Google Drive is a pretty
usable product as is.
But for those who do enjoy
having a desktop client, it is
something to take a look at.
There are also a couple
other applications
that are very similar.
One in particular that maybe
we'll do an app review of
sometime in the next few weeks,
is collections.me, and
very similar functionality in
terms of bringing Drive
contents and uni file management
to the desktop
experience.
But I already did install
Archy here.
And you can take a look
at the application.
I have one little nit in just
the dimensions of the UI.
It's a little narrow for me.
I prefer to go a little
widescreen.
But you can see here
we actually
have our Drive content.
Authentication was very easy.
It's using OAuth.
And the first thing that happens
when you launch the
app for the first time is, it
will present a pop-up webpage
for entering your Google
credentials.
I already went through that.
But we can see here, it
connected to my account.
And of course, we can
click on files.
It will launch them in
whatever the native
application is for that type.
And you can also do things
like create new files.
In fact, you can even
create new Google
documents, for example.
And I'll just do this.
We'll just create this.
And the nice thing is for the
native Google Doc formats,
when we try to open that, it's
actually going to launch this
in a web browser where I can
then go edit this file.
So, a pretty nice experience for
working with native Google
Doc formats and also pretty nice
for working with a file
on your desktop.
Of course, we have
the Sync client.
If for whatever reason you're
not using that, and you just
want to quickly add something to
Google Drive from anywhere
in your file system,
you can just drag
something right into Archy.
And it will just do an upload
into Google Drive.
In fact, let's go over to
drive.google.com, and we
should see that content
there when that loads.
There are some things that Archy
did in the UI that I
think are actually pretty cool
and a little bit different
than how we do navigation
on Google Drive itself.
So one is we have some really
nice quick views here for
accessing our content.
If I want to quickly find
my starred items, I can
click on the star.
If I want to look at folders
I have in here, and
Trash and so on.
And the one that's really
cool, actually, is this
Contacts view.
So one of the permissions
Archy asks
for is Google Contacts.
And it pulls in a lot
of information here.
So you can actually see we
get a nice profile view.
We can see pictures of the
people from our Contacts.
And the even cooler part is, it
will actually show you how
many items you have shared
with each of these users.
So we can see here I have this
Demo account on one of our
domains that have, it says,
98 shared items.
I can just drill into this, and
it will show me all of the
items I have shared
with that account.
So that's actually really a nice
navigation feature that
they added, which is not
something that is easily seen
in the Drive web UI,
so kind of a pretty
cool innovation there.
And likewise, I can go click
on my wife, see what I have
shared with her, and so on.
It's a pretty well-done
application.
If you take a look at their menu
options, if you have a
lot of different things, they've
built in the Google
Drive sharing.
So you can see here, I could
actually just click on the
little Share icon,
and I can just
share it my other account.
And they'll manage that.
And of course, that will do the
same sharing that happens
if you were to share this
through the web UI.
You can do it from here.
We can get the link for that
file, change visibility--
if you want to make it public,
available on a domain--
all of those are here,
changing ownership.
And pretty much anything that
you can do in the Drive UI or
through the Sync client you
can do through Archy.
And they actually integrated
some contact management.
A little bit of a UI issue in
that this is grayed out unless
you happen to be on
the Contact view.
But if I want to create a new
contact for, I don't know--
Hopefully there's nobody named
Joe at exemple.com.
But we can add that, and that's
going to be added into
my Contacts, synced in there.
So that same contact information
is now, of course,
in Gmail, on my phone,
wherever.
So overall, it's a really nicely
integrated experience.
I haven't really run into too
many issues in using it so
far, other than just a
few minor issues with
how the UI is done.
You can see here, here's that
file I uploaded earlier.
And overall, it's really cool.
I did mention earlier there's
one other application that, if
you are interested in a desktop
experience for Google
Drive, that might be another
interesting one to check out.
And possibly we'll do an
app review of this.
Maybe we can even do a little
bit of a head to head and see
which comes out on top.
But Collections is also worth
investigating and trying out
if you have a chance.
This one goes a little bit
beyond just Google Drive.
It does Facebook and Instagram
and everything.
But a really cool idea for
giving it that desktop view of
all your files, in the cloud,
no matter where
you're coming from.
But for Archy, it's a really
solid application.
I would like a little bit more
flexibility in the UI and just
to be able to change
the view--
maybe do a tile view, like we
have in the Drive web UI-- for
a little bit more
visual browsing.
But other than just a few minor
issues, it's a really
cool application for Mac
users, which I am.
And I probably will be giving
this a try at home a little
bit more and seeing
if it sticks.
So "good job" to the guys
that work on Archy.
And that is it for today.
Thank you, everyone.
And we will see you next week.
[MUSIC PLAYING]